it's as if there's an insistence and
maybe it's psychologically rooted to
some degree to reduce the entire
intractable complexity of the Middle
East to a single point of conflict and
you can imagine the psychological
advantage of that it's because you
reduce an irreducible set of problems to
something hypothetically comprehensible
let's take a step back the idea that
there's a Middle East conflict singular
is ridiculous I mean you could solve the
israeli-palestinian issue tomorrow and
it's not going to impact what's
happening in Yemen or in Libya or in
Iraq in 10 other places uh countries
around the region but everybody focused
on this being a Middle East Peace Prize
it's not a middle east peace process it
may be an israeli-palestinian peace
process if you solve that conflict maybe
it'll have some positive impact uh
beyond that conflict but in the Middle
East you have a battle that is going on
between the forces of modernity and
medievalism Israel is clear early on the
force for modernity
[Music]
hello everyone I am very uh privileged I
would say and happy today to be speaking
with Ambassador Ronald dermer I've been
investigating the background and the
significance of the Abraham Accords
which are a peace initiative signed a
few years ago
aimed at stabilizing and bringing
prosperity and security and opportunity
to the Middle East and
I became aware of these Accords somewhat
late in some sense given what appears to
be their significance and they look to
me like the most
uh noteworthy move towards something
approximating peace in the Middle East
that might have occurred in the last
certainly since the second world war
perhaps since the first world war that's
really saying something in such a
fractious world where so much of the
conflict has been centered in that area
as it has been for so many thousands of
years so I'm doing some background
investigation into the Accords trying to
find out their strengths and weaknesses
trying to separate the wheat from the
chaff and give credit where credit is
due and I talked to the American
ambassador to Israel a while back who
was signally important in bringing these
about and now I'm reversing that by
speaking to Ronald durmer and uh
and I'm going to share that with you so
you can make up your own mind in so far
as that's possible I'll start with a
brief bio of Ambassador dermer
and then we'll move to a discussion of
the Abraham Accords in their details and
in their context and and some of the
associated moves on the political and
strategic front that have been uh that
were undertaken in Ambassador dermer's
term so that's the plan for this
conversation and so welcome aboard
Ronald durmer on american-born Israeli
political consultant slash Diplomat
served as the Israeli ambassador to the
U.S from 2013.
to 2021
in 2004 dermer and Nate and sharansky
co-authored the best-selling the case
for democracy the power of freedom to
overcome tyranny and Terror which has
been translated into ten languages
he served as Israel's economic Envoy to
the U.S from 2005 to 2008 and then for
four years as senior advisor to former
Israeli PM's Benjamin Netanyahu for four
years
from 2013 to 2021 Mr dermer was Israeli
ambassador to the U.S
as netanyahu's top advisor he worked
closely with his U.S counterparts on
securing long-term military assistance
and missile defense funding for Israel
moved the American Embassy to Jerusalem
attaining U.S recognition of Israeli
sovereignty over the Golan Heights
implementing the maximum pressure
campaign against Iran and achieving as I
mentioned the Breakthrough Abraham
Accords which normalized Israel's
relation with several Arab Nations
Mr dermer is currently a non-resident
distinguished fellow at jinsa the Jewish
Institute for National Security of
America he's co-host of the podcast
diplomatically Incorrect and has assured
me that he is in fact diplomatically
incorrect a partner at exigent capital a
boutique investment firm in Jerusalem
and serves on the board of netspark a
leading Israeli internet filtering
technology company so welcome to my
YouTube channel and podcast Ambassador
dermer and I'm pleased that you're here
and willing to talk to me and I'd like
you to take over the conversation here
and introduce the audience who is
watching and listening to the Abraham
Accords and your understanding of their
nature and significance and the process
by which they came to be
so it's a pleasure to be with you uh
Jordan and uh I'm also thrilled to be
here because there is a slight chance
that uh that my children will actually
watch this so they can be my audience as
well because they won't listen to me
around the dinner table but they are big
fans of yours so uh I'm looking forward
to them actually listening to their
father for a change so the Abraham
Accords
if we're trying to understand the
Abraham Accords which happened in the
summer of 2020. it's very interesting
because
Israel had its first peace agreement
with Egypt in 1979 so we waited for 30
years Israel was established in 1948 it
was three decades before we had our
first peace agreement with Egypt which
was definitely a breakthrough uh and I
think changed Israel's not only the
military equation regarding Israel and
its and its neighbors but had a huge
impact
um on Israel's strategic position in the
region then we had to wait another 15
years in 1994 when we had a peace
between Israel and Jordan
and between the second and the third we
had to wait over a quarter Century 26
years until 2020 on August 13 2020 there
was a phone call between prime minister
Netanyahu president Trump and Muhammad
bin Zaid who then was the Crown Prince
of the Emirates the United Arab Emirates
and today is the ruler of the United
Arab Emirates and that was a
breakthrough well we only had to wait
about 25 days for the next breakthrough
to happen which happened in early
September with a call with the king of
Bahrain the Prime Minister and the
president and then you had the Abram
Accords which were formally signed on
September 15 2020 so we had two
immediately after those Accords were
signed two more uh countries Sudan and
Morocco increased the number to four
countries four Arab countries that had
done peace or normalization agreements
with Israel and what is striking
is how little attention is paid to the
fact that in the first 72 years of
Israel's history we have two peace
agreements with Arab countries and in a
four or five month period in 2020 you
had four agreements now how did that
happen now there's a lot of reasons why
this has been dismissed by a lot of
people around the world because it
actually I think breaks a paradigm that
it existed for many many decades is also
maybe we'll give political credit to
people that they don't want to give
political credit to but in understanding
what changed in the region and what
enabled ultimately the Abraham Accords
and by here the Abraham Accords is
specifically the surfacing of Israel's
relations with our Arab Partners
particularly in the Gulf if you want to
understand in my view the Abraham
Accords you really have to go back about
20 years
I'll take you back
to 2002 you may remember I don't know if
you were following the Middle East in
those days but in May 2002 the Saudis
put forward
what was called the Arab peace
initiative
in May 2002 now a lot of people thought
that was a breakthrough for the region I
didn't I actually thought that that was
a con job in the sense that a few months
earlier about eight or nine months
earlier on September 11
2001 19 hijackers
had had flown planes into a building the
World Trade Center head down the plane
uh in Pennsylvania and 15 of those 19
hijackers were Saudis and they were
responsible for the murder of nearly 3
000 Americans so they faced enormous
pressure
on them to do something and if you know
a little bit about the history of Saudi
Arabia there was a bond that the ruling
family in Saudi Arabia the sauds family
made with the wahab family which is the
wahhabis
and part of that
um deal that they made enabled the
wahhabis not only to control the
education system within Saudi Arabia but
also to promote a particularly virulent
brand of Islam all over the world
through the mosque that they had funded
that was the deal that the Saudis made
and 911 was a product of that not
because the Saudis directly were
involved in it or directly ordered it
because the Saudi regime had actually
enabled this infrastructure of radical
Islam to develop and ultimately it blew
up on September 11
2001. now think about the situation if
you're Saudi Arabia
how how much pressure you have on you to
do something so about eight months after
those September 11th attacks they called
in the reporter from The New York Times
a columnist Tom Friedman I believe who
went to Riyadh and he met with one of
the senior Saudi leaders and he opened a
a desk drawer and pulled out a peace
plan and all of a sudden the Saudis in
the public imagination went from being
Terror Masters to peacemakers but the
real question Jordan is this if you
would have asked the leaders of Saudi
Arabia in 2002
if you would have asked that if you
could wave a magic wand and end the
arab-israeli conflict or end the
israeli-palestinian conflict which are
not the same conflict which we'll get
into but if you could wave a magic wand
and end those conflicts would you
and the answer in 2002 in my view was no
I think they had no desire to do it I
think the conflict served their purposes
it helped divert
from a lot of bad things that were
happening in the Kingdom
and I think a lot of the British and the
French and the American diplomats fell
for the nonsense that the center of all
the problems and maladies of the Middle
East is the israeli-palestinian conflict
so they had no strategic interest in
solving the conflict period full stop
now let's fast forward 10 years not to
2020 let's talk about 2012. maybe even a
little bit beforehand but around 2012.
if you would have asked
the leaders of Saudi Arabia
if they could wave their magic wand
would they end the Israeli Arab conflict
would they end the israeli-palestinian
conflict the answer then was yes now
what changed in that decade
I'll tell you what didn't change they
didn't translate herzl who was the the
Visionary of modern Zionism they didn't
translate his Jewish State his famous
book into Arabic and you didn't see a
wave of Zionism spread across the Sands
of Arabia
um what changed was a fundamental
shift in their understanding not only in
Saudi Arabia but throughout the Gulf of
what their interests are and this was a
result of several factors that came
together
to I think change their approach to
Israel and to many other issues even
internal issues we can get to but
certainly to Israel one of the changes
that happened was the Arab Spring
you remember that in
you had Tunisia underwent this
revolution you saw it in Egypt you saw
Libya you saw Syria some of them were
violent some of them were not violent in
Yemen in Iraq all across the region
things were starting to get unstable
and so regimes that were certain of
their hold on power for decades to come
were less certain that's the first thing
second thing is you had the rise of Iran
as a very dangerous power in the region
and that was happening before 2012 but
it sort of shifted into overdrive in
those years as Obama the Obama
Administration pursued a policy of
appeasement with Iran rather than
confrontation with Iran and Iran is a
Shia radical power they not only
threatened the state of Israel which
everyone knows uh with destruction but
they also threatened their Sunni Arab
neighbors and as I would sometimes tell
my
my Arab friends they want Riyadh for
breakfast
uh they want Jerusalem for lunch and
frankly they want New York for dinner I
don't know if Toronto may be a midnight
snack but the Shia radical power of Iran
threatens them and you see Iran getting
stronger and stronger as they feel less
certain now you had another factor which
is the rise of Sunni radicalism and that
would be in the form of Isis now Iran as
I said is a Shia radical power they're
also Sunni radical forces Al-Qaeda
who perpetrated 911 that Sunni
radicalism 1.0 I Isis is 2.0 and
there'll be a 3.0 and these regimes in
the Gulf
are also frightened of them
so you've got this Iranian tiger whose
claws are getting longer and teeth are
getting sharper you've got this Isis
leopard that is roaming throughout that
region chopping off heads decimating
populations and instilling fear in a
very wide swath of territory and here is
another factor that is critical to
understand the change in the Middle East
when that Iranian tiger and Isis leopard
is rising and becoming stronger the 800
pound American gorilla is leaving the
building
so the withdrawal from the Middle East
of the United States at least the
reduction of the military footprint of
the United States in the Middle East I
think that helps seize the minds of
plenty of people in the Gulf because if
there is one thing Jordan that connects
Obama
Trump and Biden and they don't want to
be in the same sentence with one another
on nearly anything
none of them are looking to send more
American troops to the Middle East
so when you see these threats that tiger
and that leopard getting stronger and
the 800-pound gorilla has left
so they say there's a 200 pound gorilla
with a keeper on called Israel let's
work in closer cooperation with that so
the fundamental thing to appreciate
is they had a different understanding of
their most vital security interests and
working closely with Israel helps them
Advance the interest second issue now
is the rise of Israel as a global
technological power
and Israel is the second great source of
innovation
outside of Silicon Valley silicon
valleys one Israel that ecosystem that
we have for Innovation is remarkable and
we're not just a great innovator when it
comes to Technologies in traditional
Fields like agriculture or water
they're also take an area like cyber
which has both civilian or military
applications so Israel is one tenth of
one percent of the world's population
with all of nine million people
but we account for about 20
of private investment in cyber so
Israel's punching 200 times above its
weight in cyber so we're not a country
the size of New Jersey with all of nine
million people as I say in cyber Israel
is bigger than a China but there are
other areas autonomous vehicles
artificial intelligence all of these
Technologies of the future and maybe
we'll get a chance to talk about it why
Israel has that ecosystem how we
developed it but we have it now if you
think about the Arab world's traditional
boycott of Israel
it's about as intelligent as Oregon
Nevada Utah Wyoming Colorado New Mexico
Arizona and half a California boycotting
Silicon Valley it makes no sense and to
the extent that you have leaders in the
region
who care about the future of their
regimes which they all do but who are
smart enough to understand that the
world still needs oil today but who
knows what's going to happen in 20 30 40
50 years they have to prepare their
countries for a different future and
Muhammad bin Zaid the Crown Prince
of the Emirates is certainly one of
those leaders and I think Muhammad bin
Salman and we could talk about khashoggi
and all of that but I think he's also
one of those leaders and they're looking
around the region and the bottom line is
this they see that there's security
interests and their economic interests
are tied to a partnership with Israel
they want to actually move into an
alliance with Israel but they do have a
big problem
these regimes have been poisoning their
populations against Israel
for six seven decades so it's very hard
for them to turn on a dime and say all
of a sudden hey you know we need to do
this for the good of our countries it is
very difficult they don't have
democracies they're authoritarian
systems
some people say it's you know more
benevolent or less benevolent but
they're all authoritarian systems
um but public opinion in these systems
matter and they have to navigate
particularly when you've seen in other
countries a whole regime's go down
because they didn't respond to public
opinion
we'll have more with Ambassador Ron
dermer in just a moment but first I want
to tell you about Birch gold
experts warn that President Joe Biden's
plan to forgive student debt could cost
over 500 billion dollars their solution
to hire 87 000 new IRS agents and
squeeze taxpayers with an additional 1.2
million audits per year there's never
been a better reason to diversify at
least some of your savings in precious
metals and protect those Savings in a
tax sheltered retirement account with
Birch gold group
Jordan to 989898 and Birch gold will
send you a free info kit on how to
diversify into silver and gold tax-free
Birch gold has an A plus rating with a
Better Business Bureau countless
five-star reviews and thousands of
satisfied customers text j-o-r-d-a-n to
989898 to claim your free no obligation
info kit on how to protect your savings
with gold text Jordan to 989898
[Music]
so let me let me summarize just so that
I make sure I've got this so
um you made a couple of points at the
beginning one of which was that these
peace agreements multiple peace
agreements four of them
um emerged in a very short period of
time after a very slow process of
similar peace agreements extending over
about a 70-year period and that there
was some movement towards this in 2002
by the Saudis but that was mostly
reaction to the negative publicity
associated with 911. you said that um
the Saudis however by 2014 because of
all sorts of changes on the
international scene including the
American withdrawal and the rise of the
Arab Spring and the dawning realization
of Israel's value as a tech and
Innovative Hub had convinced many Arab
leaders in the region including the
Saudis that
it was more intelligent to pay attention
to the threat that was posed to their
regimes into the stability of the area
by internal dissidents both on the
Shiite and the and the Sunni side than
to be concerned with the
israeli-palestinian conflict and to
ignore the potential benefit that
partnership with Israel might bring
about and that shifted harden up by 2014
so that even the Saudis who might have
been regarded as particularly
intractable because of their partnership
with the wahhabis were willing to
contemplate the idea that the proper
pathway forward for them was in fact a
normalization of of relations with
Israel and the development of the kind
of economic stability and Military
security that might ensure the longevity
of their regimes so just a couple a
couple fine points on which on what you
said first of all it's before 2014. by
2012 it was already there I would say we
we're not we went into the prime
minister's office to I was I joined
prime minister Netanyahu there as a
senior advisor in 2009 very quickly we
could see a situation where we were
assessing the region in the same way as
the Saudis because you'd have officials
presidents Prime Ministers Senators who
would come through the region and a lot
of them would be coming from Riyadh or
coming from Abu Dhabi and they would say
to prime minister Netanyahu you know
what
um your analysis of the problems of the
region are the exact same as the
analysis that we're hearing in the gulf
and so there there was clearly a
marriage of interest at that point uh
the other thing I would say just to to
clarify
um it's not about the dissidents that
happened because my my view I wrote a
book with Nathan sharansky about the
case for democracy when I think of
dissidents I think about you know people
who were fighting for for freedom and
for political all his civil rights and
human rights obviously these are about
terrorists I mean yeah I was thinking
more about the Iranians than Isis
actually right right no so Iranian and
Isis I agree with you I would say it's
it's terrorists who want to not only
destroy their regimes but they want to
actually take the whole world back to
the 8th century and you know there's
Sunni terrorists that want to take us to
the 8th Century the Shia terrorists that
want to take us to the 10th Century
maybe they'll get together and they'll
make a compromise and try to take us all
back to the 9th century but they're all
bad and they're a huge problem for any
regime that is actually focused on the
future and does don't want to go back to
the Dark Ages okay okay now how are the
now you you laid a fair bit of stress on
the positive Saudi contribution to this
peace process but the Saudis aren't
signatories yet and maybe they will be
but I have heard from many informed
sources that they were powerful players
behind the scene and were fundamentally
not only on board with this but in some
sense enabling it I'm wondering given
there the the their the bet with the
devil in some sense that they made with
the wahhabis I'm saying that
metaphorically to some degree how are
the Saudis managing to move towards
normalization of relations with Israel
given their partnership with a
particularly uh fundamentalist brand of
well the fundamentalist brand of of of
of the wahhabis how are they managing
that and is what's the remaining threat
there to the district further
distribution and maintenance of this
peace process
well to me the Saudis are the invisible
hand behind the whole Abraham Accords
it's hard for me to imagine that it
would have gotten off the ground without
at least their tacit support So Bahrain
if you've been there you know it's a
bridge uh literally a bridge from Saudi
Arabia you could in American term see it
as sort of the 51st state of uh of Saudi
Arabia so the idea that the bahrainis
would have made a peace with Israel with
the Saudis giving a red light I just
don't believe that that would be the
case and I think even the Emirates
despite the the real leadership of
Muhammad bin Zaid mbz I think if the
Saudis had a complete red light against
doing this and we're fighting it
actively I think a very hard to imagine
that he would have agreed to move
forward also remember that in order to
get from Israel to the Emirates you got
to fly over Saudi Arabia unless you want
to go around and fly over Iraq and Iran
which I don't think anybody wants to do
so the Saudis made their airspace
available for planes flying over so
there's no question that they were
behind it and I think they probably saw
Bahrain and the Emirates as a as a trial
balloon to see how that goes to see how
the public their own Publix because you
know you never know exactly about public
opinion in these societies that are more
closed Societies in a democracy you can
tell where people are because they say
it openly and freely on all the
television stations and everybody's
criticizing everybody in these countries
when you do a big event like that a big
move for peace
you know you you maybe think your
assessment is right about where the
public is but you don't know for sure uh
and I think that was part of that
process unfortunately and maybe we'll
have a chance to get into this
unfortunately the Trump Administration
began the Abraham Accords in the final
months of the presidency rather than in
the first months of the presidency and I
think that was a missed opportunity
certainly better late than never when it
comes to a breakthrough piece but this
was something that was possible to do
years before because as I said already
in 2012 2013
the they were ready they if the answer
to that question and when you're
thinking about peace the first question
is do these people actually want peace
forget about them doing the dance
internationally to try to get to try to
get on the right side of what popular
Elite opinion is it to be seen as
peacemakers that they always wanted but
would they actually want to make p is I
think that they were already there about
a decade ago and we tried I I must
confess we tried with the Obama
Administration Israel did in its second
term
to convince them to move along this
track and to try to focus their efforts
on achieving an Israeli Arab peace and
and then Kerry was Secretary of State
and I spoke to him countless times about
pursuing it and explaining that the
Arabs were ready and he was insistent
and this was been this had been
conventional wisdom for two decades he
said the only way that you're going to
get these Arabs to make peace with you
is if you make peace
with the Palestinians and I would have
people not just Democrats but also
Republicans for two decades saying you
know if you make peace with the
Palestinians you'll have peace with some
two dozen Arab states and I would say
well that may be tautological you may be
right they'll have no other big excuse
that they can put forward but what if
the Palestinians don't want to make
peace does that mean that we have to
just wait when these countries interests
are to move forward so we try with
secretary Kerry so many times to
convince him to take this approach he
instead before he did the Iran deal
which is also connected to this
but he tried to again use the same
formula and a failed approach to
peacemaking and went down this
israeli-palestinian rabbit hole which
was a Road to Nowhere why was there so
much insistence I've heard this from
other people that I've talked to here
and you see this playing out on the
media landscape there's there's there's
it's as if there's an insistence and
maybe it's psychologically rooted to
some degree to reduce the entire
intractable complexity of the Middle
East to a single point of conflict and
you can imagine the psychological
advantage of that it's because you
reduce an irreducible set of problems to
something hypothetically comprehensible
so you focus it on Israel versus
Palestine and then that becomes a an
intractable moral issue to some degree
because then it depends on which side of
the argument that you take and that
seems to have completely stymied any
attempts to well do the sorts of things
to go around in some sense or to find
alternative routes in the manner that
you describe but why do you why do you
think that the Israel versus Palestine
conflict has become such an unbelievable
sticking point for this kind of movement
uh what are this what are the
sociological and economic reasons I
suppose in geopolitical reasons why that
might be the case
I mean carries Carrie's attitude seems
Seems in some sense incomprehensible
given that you were providing evidence
that there was at least some possibility
that there was an alternative route
yeah listen I I think that you that's a
deeper question that you're asking now
is why people have the view of Israel
that they do I mean let's take a step
back the idea that there's a Middle East
conflict singular is ridiculous I mean
you could solve the israeli-palestinian
issue tomorrow and it's not going to
impact what's happening in Yemen or in
Libya or in Iraq in 10 other places uh
countries around the region but
everybody focused on this being a Middle
East Peace Prize it's not a middle east
peace process it may be an
israeli-palestinian peace process if you
solve that conflict maybe it'll have
some positive impact uh beyond that
conflict but in the Middle East you have
a battle that is going on between the
forces of modernity and medievalism
that's what the conflict is and there
are Sunni forces on the in on the modern
side and Shia forces on the modern side
and there are Sunni forces on the on the
medieval side and Shia forces on the
medieval side Israel is clearly on the
force for modernity as a country as a
society as the one real democracy if you
came to Israel which should have all the
rights Free Speech uh freedom of the
press independent courts the things that
we take for for granted in Democratic
societies you don't have that anywhere
else and these societies are trying to
overcome centuries of of of this tyranny
to see if they can chart a path for a
different a future but the focus on the
israeli-palestinian conflict why
everybody believes uh that this conflict
is the root of everything I think a lot
of it has to do with the demonization of
Israel for many many decades because if
you can cast Israel as the villain in
that theater and we're the powerful
force against the Palestinians who are
the weak party and so therefore if it
can all be cast to Israel and Israel can
be blamed I think that's sitting on
thousands of years of History I'll tell
you a story about how
how absurd the israeli-palestinian
conflict is as the source of all the
Region's problems let alone the world's
problems and by way of background I
remember there was uh Obama's former
National Security adviser I think it was
General Jones once gave an interview and
he said something very bizarre he said
you know if I were God and I came to
Obama and I told him to to resolve one
issue in the world I would tell him to
resolve the israeli-palestinian conflict
you know it was bizarre a bizarre
statement but it shows the centrality
that this conflict has held and even
we'll get to it with Trump where Trump
was also at the beginning like the Holy
Grail of peacemaking is you're going to
solve the israeli-palestinian conflict
yeah it makes me wonder to some degree
too to to how it's tied to a very deep
underlying that Dynamic which is
something like that's being played out
over thousands of years in many
different places as that that makes the
Jews in some sense the Eternal scapegoat
you know when it's so convenient that
you can point if Matt imagine you're a
leader that's beset by all sorts of
ethical troubles in the Middle East and
you can point to The Outsiders who are
the Jews let's say who also happen to be
successful which is extremely annoying
and you can say like the Germans did in
Nazi Germany well look at those
successful Outsiders they must be
oppressive thieves and then all the
attention that might be paid to the
distributed evil is localized to that
particularized and externalized evil and
that's just hyper convenient for
everyone involved and so it seems to me
that there's something like that going
on in addition to many other things I
agree with you it's it's a potent
cocktail I think part of that cocktail
for decades was essentially oil
because you have oil producing states
and Israel is seen as being on the other
side you've got 22 Arab states you've
got 57 Muslim states so what are you
going to you're going to stand with the
one Jewish state in in the region and
you see how oil affects the politics of
Russia and Ukraine and everything around
there so oil played a big role but I
think it's also sitting on this Powder
Keg that goes back uh a couple thousand
years with this attempt not just to make
the Jews let's say a scapegoat but also
to cast them as some sort of source of
evil in the world and the problem of the
world well you you do have this weird
situation that you described so you said
if I got my figures right that Israel is
one tenth of one percent of the world's
population but responsible for something
like 20 percent of a major element of
technological development and so you
have this not only do you have this
status on the Jewish side as an extreme
minority very tiny population considered
by global standards and generally within
any country but you also have the
additional problem of a tiny minority
who are disproportionately successful
and at an exponential scale and so you
can also imagine that people looking at
that have
a moral problem to solve which is
something like well there's hardly any
of these people and they're really
really successful and so either they're
doing something right in some
fundamental way which implies that we're
doing something wrong or they're thieves
and villains and there's a fair bit of
moral hazard in a calculation like that
because obviously the easier Pathway to
take rather than the radical
self-examination that might be required
to determine what you're doing wrong is
to point the finger and say Well they're
obviously just thieves and parasites and
should be scourged and I mean it's not
like that's only happened once it's
happened it's happening continually and
it's pretty much happened forever no it
gets first of all I think it's a it's a
it's a deeper discussion I know we're
going to do a deep dive we'll have to do
it even deeper dive on sort of the
mission of the Jews and the nature of
anti-Semitism how it developed why it
developed why you see its reemergence
today I think that's true but the the
Israel the israeli-palestinian conflict
you know to cast Israel as the world's
Jew that's the kind of new form of
anti-Semitism to single out Israel for
special treatment to treat it by a
standard that you treat no other country
in the world and that when Israel does
something wrong because you know we're
not a perfect country no country is
perfect and and somebody could make a
mistake uh somebody could do something
in the society that's wrong we're the
only country that when something is done
that is wrong we supposedly have no
right to exist which I think is a much
deeper question of the role the Jews
have played in the world you know Abu
ghraib I remember happening about 20
years ago in Iraq and people were
rightly appalled by that and people
called for heads to roll and all sorts
of things to happen nobody says America
doesn't have a right to exist because of
Abu gray but every day multiple times a
day the second anything that Israel does
is perceive to be wrong we no longer
have a right to exist but I wanted I
wanted to tell you a story just when
you're looking about the the scalar or
the scope of the israeli-palestinian
conflict when you're thinking about
global Affairs a story that happened to
me when I was Ambassador so new
ambassadors to Washington you usually
get you pay courtesy calls to other
ambassadors and by way of tradition you
you meet about 10 other ambassadors so
when I came to Washington the first
Ambassador I went to see was the
ambassador of Egypt to the United States
then the ambassador of Jordan to the
United States who are peace Partners I
think I met the ambassador of England in
Germany and a whole others a whole bunch
of others I found myself in my seven and
a half years I met a lot of ambassadors
who they would come to town and it was
their and we would find ourselves in
their top 10 list of ambassadors that
they wanted to meet with and I would
never turn down
a meeting with another Ambassador for
two reasons number one is Israel is not
in a position to turn down anybody any
friends potential friends and the second
thing is if you meet a smart Ambassador
it usually saves you about five years of
reading The Economist which I don't
really like to read The Economist so one
particular day
I come back and it's after a long day I
had seven or eight meetings White House
Congress and I come back and in my
waiting room there is the ambassador of
Burundi to the United States
so I said give me give me a moment I
went into my office and I have to admit
on your podcast
I had to look up and Google Burundi like
I knew it was in Africa but that's about
it I didn't know what it bordered I
didn't know anything about its history
I did the Wikipedia thing in two minutes
to try to get as much information as I
can and then I invited him into my
office and we started speaking and this
happened to me that day it's very rare
for me it might be rare for you
that day it happens about twice a year I
was actually tired of listening to
myself speak
I was so exhausted having talked for
about eight hours I just didn't want to
talk about Iran about the peace process
about anything to deal with Israel and I
know nothing about Burundi and I get
this very smart guy I think he was
Harvard educated
in my office and I started peppering him
with questions about Burundi what do you
make in Burundi what do you export from
Burundi what are you trying to achieve
in the United States and then I asked
him do you have a security problem
and he says not since 2004. I said what
happened in 2004 he said well in 1994
you had the genocide of Rwanda that
spilled over to Burundi
and we had a terrible violence over the
next decade and there was some sort of
ceasefire peace agreement in 2004 and
since then we haven't had a security
problem and I asked him how many people
died in that decade between 94 and 2004.
and he says 300 000. I said really 300
000 I said how many people you think
have died in the history of the
israeli-palestinian conflict now this
meeting is about 2015. so we're talking
about a century almost a century in 1920
when you had an attack outside of the
immigration office in Jaffa until 2015
where I'm sitting with this ambassador
and he's a very intelligent person and
he thinks about it for a while probably
30 seconds or so and then he said 2
million
and I said well you're pretty close
you're only off by two zeros because
it's about twenty thousand twenty two
thousand Israelis and Palestinians have
died in the century of conflict
uh since 19 from 1920 22 000. now if you
take the Israeli Arab conflict
where you take all the soldiers of
Israel who have died all the victims of
Terror the wars that we have fought and
you add Egypt Egyptian casualties and
Lebanese casualties and Syrian
casualties and Jordanian casualties you
take the entire conflict you get to 125
000. of that 125 000 about a fifth are
the israeli-palestinian conflict without
getting into who's right who's wrong
just in terms of the number of people
who have died in this conflict this
ambassador's jaw drops
he cannot believe it he said why is the
whole world obsessed with the
israeli-palestinian conflict yeah well
there's a Biblical phrase right the
biblical phrase is to those
to whom much has been given much will be
demanded and that seems to be the
Eternal position of the Jews in some
real sense right so I don't know what to
make of that exactly but that's one way
of looking at but what I told him in
that meeting just to just to to finish
the point is I said
you know it's a problem for us that the
world is obsessed with Israel and
demonizing Israel and that more
resolutions are passed at the U.N
against Israel than all the rest of the
world combined or in the so-called Human
Rights Council then or I mean seriously
if you show the statistics to your
viewers they won't even believe it it's
a farce but I said it's not just a
problem for Israel this demonization and
this piling on Israel it's a problem for
you nobody knows that 300 000 burundi's
were killed in a decade that is an
enormous tragedy and barely anybody even
knows about it because the world is
obsessed with Israel and he understood
it so then what I did is I said to
myself listen I don't know anything
about Burundi
so I shouldn't begrudge him for not
knowing anything about the
israeli-palestinian conflict so I
started asking other people and I would
do this question and you know you got to
set it up so you're not trying to gain
one answer and I would do it sort of
straight I'd say how many people have
been killed in the israeli-palestinian
conflict the lowest number that I got
was five hundred thousand a factor of 20
times as big and when this person who
was headed his foreign Ministry in
Europe he was the head of the Middle
East Division and the foreign minister
of one of the European countries he said
that's not true
what you're saying is not true there
hasn't been 22 000. I said well you know
it used to be an Antiquity if you wanted
to be a scholar you'd have to sit in the
Library of Alexandria and peruse Scrolls
for a few decades now all you need to do
is Google it so go into the palm of your
hand that ever expanding library and go
look it up and he was sort of stunned
and so it is ridiculous the obsession
with Israel forget about the fact that
we have focused only on the
israeli-palestinian conflict and we have
not opened the door finally we did to
peace with the Arab states but the
obsession of the International Community
with this conflict and every single
person who dies is of course a tragedy
for that family if you're looking at it
from the point of view of the
International Community with that which
threatens peace and security
it's a non-event and yet they've made so
much focus on this for the last century
and they wasted a lot of time so with
Kerry getting back to the to the point
that I wanted to make about Kerry
is I tried and Netanyahu tried
incessantly to tell him John you know
they've known each other for three
decades there's a real opportunity here
you need to focus on it Netanyahu spoke
about it at the U.N this is before Trump
this is a couple years before Trump
where he says never in my lifetime has
I've seen the possibilities that I see
today the Arab world is in a different
place for all the reasons that we
discussed but he would not listen he was
focused on the Holy Grail of peacemaking
and this Rabbit Hole to nowhere because
unfortunately the Palestinians have not
abandoned their desire to destroy the
one and only Jewish state which is a
separate question from the Abram Accords
they have not abandoned it and we try to
convince Carrie
go and focus on the errors and he
refused to do it in fact there's a
famous video I don't know if you have
links that you put on your podcast where
you can see Carrie who says there are
those in Israel or political leaders in
Israel I think he said
who say that you can have A Separate
Peace
between the Arab states in Israel
without first having peace with the
Palestinians and he goes no no no no no
no no
and I said after it's too bad he didn't
say no six times because then we would
have had six peace agreements and not
four because he said no four times but
we tried very much with secretary Kerry
and we failed they weren't focused on it
and and one of the reasons why they
didn't do it is you not only had this
Paradigm that goes back from Oslo that
all roads to peace must go through
Ramallah so everybody's waiting for the
Palestinians to deign to make to even
meet with Israel let alone make peace
with Israel but everybody's waiting on
the Palestinians and solving this
conflict and because the Palestinians
are holding the line inevitably more and
more pressure gets brought to bear on
Israel because we're seen as the
powerful party
and you know what happens in a world
where power and Justice are seen as
buckets in the well which is the kind of
world that we're living in now so all
the pressure comes onto Israel and um
there were many other reasons why why
Kerry decided to pursue it there was
also skepticism that when Netanyahu was
saying to have peace with the Arabs he
was really just trying to avoid making
hard concessions to the Palestinians
because making peace with the Arabs
could be peace for peace and not land
for peace so instead of having the code
quote-unquote courageous decisions of
sacrificing vital the vital interests of
your country to make peace with with the
Palestinians
um he wants to move to the Arabs where
it'll be an easier path for him to do it
without the political risk that's how
they thought about it not realizing hey
the Middle East has changed there's a
real opportunity here and here's
something that people do not know
we also failed with the Trump
administration at the beginning
they were not prepared to see that as
well
um about a week after
I don't think I've said it publicly but
a week after
I went to visit Trump at Trump Tower
this is a week after he gets elected
sorry in November 2016.
it's a Trump Tower
and I walk into his office and the first
thing he says to me is so you think we
can make peace
and I said with whom
and he said the Palestinians almost
surprised by an Irish my question and I
said no but we can make peace with
several Arab states
right that's what we were telling the
previous administration we started
telling him that now fast forward three
months Netanyahu visits Washington his
first trip to Washington as prime
minister with Trump in office it's
February 2017.
what Netanyahu says to Trump and I can
say it because he mentioned it recently
publicly as well for the first time
what Netanyahu said to Trump in that
meeting he said 75 years ago there's a
picture of FDR sitting with the leader
of Saudi Arabia and that helped
establish a 75-year alliance between the
United States and Saudi Arabia and he
says to Trump says get a boat you me MBS
mbz we change history
that's what he said now it took us about
two years
to convince them
of the opportunity
that it was real because and this is
really due more to president Trump who
deserves a lot of credit for a lot of
decisions that he made but at the
beginning he was really fixated even at
the end to a certain extent he was still
fixated on the israeli-palestinian peace
process that was the Holy Grail that was
the ultimate test of whether you've
actually done something rather than
trying to do all of these agreements
that have a huge impact in the region
because a piece between Israel and Saudi
Arabia is effectively the end of the
Arab Israeli conflict it's not the end
of the israeli-palestinian conflict it's
not the end of the Israeli Iran conflict
but it's essentially the end of the of a
century-old Israeli Arab conflict and I
think that that's a goal that is worth
pursuing but it took two years
for them to see the opportunity that was
there
and then we wasted another year because
of our insane politics in Israel where
we're going from one election after the
other so by the time that President
Trump kind of put out his peace plan
which was sort of an effort to
open the door for the Palestinians if
they'd like to go through that door but
essentially it would park a real plan on
the table while Israel moves ahead and
normalizes its relations with the Arab
world that process only started in the
last year of his administration
rather than in the first year and I and
I do believe that had we done this from
the beginning of the administration
we would have a peace between Israel and
Saudi Arabia today but because we waited
too long
we only started it very late in the game
now the Trump Administration
they didn't waste the time they may not
have recognized the potential for that
breakthrough in those two years or three
years
but they didn't waste the time because
they took steps that actually
facilitated the emergence of the Abraham
Accords so what I described to you
before is the fundamentals underneath
the surface
okay so let me let me summarize some of
this too and ask then I'll ask you some
broader questions so you're you pointed
out and please correct me where I get it
wrong you pointed out that it's a
straightforward psychologically to make
the assumption that all the conflict in
the world but certainly on the conflict
in the Middle East is best
conceptualized in relationship to the
israeli-palestine conflict and now it's
morally hazardous and inappropriate and
also blinds people uh whatever the flaws
of the Jewish State might be it also
blinds people to the fact that the the
that Israel is a hyper successful State
and that has much to offer its Arab
partners and the world in terms of
technological development and Innovation
and governance and now I think that's
that's just clearly true as far as I can
see and then you pointed out that
there are many conflicts that are
riveting the Arab and Middle Eastern
world but the most fundamental of those
likely is something conceptualized as
modernity versus medievalism and that's
raging that war both on the Sunni side
and the Shiite side
um then you and so you you complexified
in some sense the Arab situation then
you pointed out as well that there were
Pathways around the israeli-palestine
conflict that were very productive that
you had been developing and that were
emerging of their own accord that the
players who were fixated on Israel
versus Palestine weren't willing to
consider including the Trump
Administration until relatively late in
the game and then
okay now so I have some questions that
come out of that that would help me and
hopefully my listeners understand the
broader context within which this is
occurring and so
it's not appropriate to produce the
complexities of the problem in the
Middle East to the israel-palestine
conflict for a variety of reasons and
you started to detail out the
complexities of the situation with
regards to this modernity versus
medievalism situation and so if I ask
you
maybe I could get you to flesh in for me
the status of other major players in the
region in relationship to a potential
Pathway to peace forward so I would like
to start by picking your brain to some
degree about both Iraq and Iran and so I
would like to to know how you see them
in relationship to well the world
geopolitical situation but to the
Abraham Accords and I would also like to
know I've always thought that the
Palestine Israel conflict was just a bit
too convenient for many major players in
the region partly because it could be
used as a scapegoat and partly because
um support for the Palestinians caused a
certain amount of intractable and
continual trouble that did this is the
moral hazard argument that did it
detract people from other sources of
unrest and instability and Corruption
obviously the Palestines are backed by
external players who are I think it's
obvious who are
capitalizing on that Conflict for their
own purposes and so
in whose interest do you think it is
primarily in the Middle East to
Foster and facilitate A continuing
non-peaceful
standoff between the Palestinians and
the Israelis
so the first is the Palestinians
themselves because they've been dining
out on this conflict now for since Oslo
really for 30 years and becoming the
wards of the International Community I'd
say the middle east is incredibly
complicated the israeli-palestinian
conflict much less so in my view the
reason why you have a conflict today is
the same reason why you had a conflict
for the last century which is the
refusal of the Palestinians to recognize
the legitimacy of a nation-state of the
Jewish people in any boundary in our
ancestral Homeland they refuse to do it
it's very it's it's very simple and
almost raw in their minds we stole their
house
and that's how they see it they don't
understand that this is the territory
you know where the Patriarchs or the
Jewish people prayed or where our
prophets preached and our King's rule is
a complete denial of any historical
connection between the Jews and the land
of Israel their refusal to accept some
sort of compromise the fact that they
haven't paid such a huge price for that
refusal because they've been supported
by various actors in the region for a
long time and actually the Abram Accords
is like the beginning of a shift away
it's the removal of the Palestinians
veto over this process and the Arab
leaders for their own interests which
we've discussed before security and
economic interest understand we're not
going to give the keys to the Middle
East to the person who's effectively the
mayor of Ramallah the leader of the
Palestinian Authority because
Palestinian politics are divided you
have Hamas which is a terror
organization that openly calls to
destroy Israel leading Gaza which is
half of the Palestinian polity then on
the other half you have this Palestinian
Authority which refuses to confront the
terrorists and all also make sure that
the next generation is fired by the same
hatred and denial of any Israel's
legitimate presence in the land because
they do it to their schools and their
media and everything else and they also
pay people actually they put them on the
payroll those who are who are terrorists
so the israeli-palestinian conflict
is a pretty simple one okay so let me
let me ask you a question about that
this is something that's bothered me for
a very long time and I think it's key to
this in some sense
so
um let me set up an analogy and it's a
dangerous analogy and it may be
inappropriate but I'm going to use it
anyways and so
um Constantinople is now Istanbul but
historically it wasn't and so you could
say in some sense that the Christians
have a claim on Constantinople and it's
not like people haven't made that claim
and so I'm not saying they have a claim
or that they don't what I am saying is
that when you look at a given region you
can look at it through the lens of
different temporal
um uh durations and the ethical
conclusion that you derive is in some
sense dependent on the expanse of the
temporal Horizon that you're willing to
consider now the argument you made for
the legitimacy of the state of of Israel
is a it's an ancient claim and then that
begs the question and I think this
really is it's an extraordinarily
difficult question
how do you know which temporal Horizon
should be most appropriately applied to
a given landscape especially given that
there are different claims and different
temporal
uh um frames of reference that are
applied to the same territory of land by
other people and I mean the same thing
is true say in North America because the
Europeans came in and obviously there
were people living here before the
Europeans came in and so it's an endless
conflict in Canada let's say in the U.S
about to what degree the people who
inhabited the territory originally have
a valid moral claim on the territory and
it's it's not like that's being resolved
I don't think we know how to resolve it
and then with the Jews you seem to have
this additional
insistence by the world that they solve
it better than anyone else and I again
that has something to do with to those
to whom more has been given more will be
demanded the Jews seem to be held
consistently to a higher moral standard
but but it is a real problem why do you
think the Palestinians should both
ethically and practically accept the
claim of the Israel State and the to
exist and the Jews to inhabit it like
because that really is the central issue
the thing the thing with your analogy in
the issue of sort of the new world we're
the Indians who came back
in the case of Constantinople you'd have
the Christians who would come back and
they would have had to have lived there
continuously and then established the
state and then the Muslim power says no
you have no right to be here like no one
would question if the Native Americans
somehow and this is not the case with
Native most peoples were lost to history
when they lost their land now the Jews
lived continuously a small Jewish
Community lived continuously for over
3000 years in the land of Israel but
Jews were dispersed all over the world
and they came back no one has ever dealt
with that where people coming back but
when you're talking about legitimacy
there's a historical legitimacy here
where we are in our ancestral Homeland
that doesn't exist anywhere else it's
not displacing the natives the Jews were
the ones who were displaced not just by
the Romans but also by the Arab Conquest
where a lot of Jews were people just
don't know history I mean most people's
sense of history as you know goes back
to breakfast so why should why should
anybody care about what happened but if
you if those historical canes don't work
for you well you could take the legal
claim and and the legal claim was that
there was an Ottoman Empire here the
Ottoman Empire collapsed the British
were given a mandate to control this
territory specifically by the League of
Nations in order to enable the
settlement of the Jews who in the 19th
century the late 19th century the spring
of nations were considered a a people
you know there are people who don't
consider the Jews of people but we have
a 4 000 year history and peoples have
rights of self-determination and so the
British were given a mandate by then the
League of Nations which folded into the
United Nations to actually affect the
settlement of that territory to enable
the Jews to establish this Homeland
there that's the legal case is Rock
Solid the historical case is Rock Solid
and to me the moral case is Rock Solid
because we're a people that the entire
world turned their backs on the Jews
anytime we were oppressed I mean Jews
would have a right to a state anyone
but to say that the Jews don't have a
right to a state in their ancestral
Homeland that seems to me lunacy now
there are people who say no people have
a right to a state
so those people who deny Israel's right
to exist that they should be no nation
states well I wouldn't call them being
anti I wouldn't say they're anti-semitic
one of the Rays that one of the measures
of anti-Semitism is are you treating
Jews to a different standard than you're
treating other people so if you believe
any people have a right to a state that
there is such a thing as a people and
what makes a people a people it can be
language it can be a common culture it
can be a common history right the one
thing that the Jews were missing
historically is they didn't have the
same land but all the elements of people
who they had so if you're going to look
around the world and you're going to say
peoples deserve States but for some
reason the Jews who their statelessness
has caused more oppression and
persecution than against any other
people in history at least any other
people that currently exists and you
know you have pogroms and you culminated
because everyone is focused on the
Holocaust which I think the Holocaust
has a certain sense distorted our view
of anti-Semitism and Jewish history
because is it is it is such a blinding
event
that happened 18 million Jews six
million are wiped out it's a third of
the Jewish people the equivalent of a
hundred million Americans or over 10
million Canadians huge numbers of people
and I used to when I was ambassador to
the United States to explain what the
Holocaust did to the Jews I would tell
Americans if you can't wrap your mind a
hundred around 100 million people
imagine a 911 every day for a century
that's what the Holocaust did to the
Jewish people so it is such a seismic
event that people don't recognize all
the anti-Semitism that came before it
all the centuries of anti-Semitism that
came before people who killed 200 000
Jews 400 000 Jews the Jews are expelled
from England and then they're expelled
from France and they're expelled from
Spain and they're expelled from Portugal
all the persecutions all the programs
all the massacres during the Crusades
before the Crusades in Antiquity in
present day you're sitting I understand
in uh in England
well they just discovered up in Norwich
oh well I don't know if you had a chance
to read that story where they have a
bunch of skeletons that they found at a
bottom of a well
and they dated those skeletons to the
12th century to the end of the 12th
century when there was a program against
the local Jewish community so
anti-Semitism has existed Century after
Century to Century and I it's a big
subject that we could maybe tackle in
the future uh but but for me the bottom
line is to make a case
where the Jewish people do not are not
by right entitled to a state is absurd
and the fact that somebody would deny it
in our own Homeland
is the height of absurdity let me ask
you one more question on the Palestinian
front then so you've made a case I would
say globally and abstractly and that's
this is not a criticism of the case
precisely that nationhood
it's reasonable to associate nationhood
with the the necessity of a state and
then you made a case that the Jews have
a legal right to the land they occupy as
a consequence of what occurred after
World War One a strong legal case and so
then I would say let's particularize
that for a minute and perhaps if I was
arguing the Palestinian case I would say
yes but it wasn't reasonable for the
world to purchase what was just and
appropriate to deliver to the Jews at
disproportionate cost to the
Palestinians the Abba Jordan the world
didn't do that the Jews did that the
Jews came and immigrated in larger
numbers there was a trickle of
immigration the Jews over the centuries
to be in the land of Israel and the holy
land but in the late 19th century with
the birth of modern Zionism and actually
Christian Zionism came about three or
four decades even before that and maybe
even further than that in the late 18th
century in the 19th century the Jews
came back settled the lands drained the
swamps purchased it a lot of times from
from Arab landowners who weren't even
present who would sell it and the
Ottoman Empire collapses so now the
question is who does this land that you
have legal deed to who does it belong to
and instead of actually having a
Palestinian national movement and this
is really their great tragedy they
didn't have a Palestinian national
movement a hundred years ago and they
don't have it today who says look guys
you have a right to be here but we have
a right to be here you know if that's
the case you're in a negotiation when
somebody says you stole our house even
if you give 99.9 back there's no justice
to your claim when another side says
it's one percent Yours by right not just
by might but by right
and it's 99 ours you're actually in a
negotiation and the re and the reason
why you have to ask yourself why did the
Palestinians deny history so Arafat went
to Clinton at Camp David Yasser Arafat
the leader of the Palestinians at the
time 20 years ago Goes to Camp David and
tells Clinton there was never a temple
on the Temple Mount like why does he say
that
and why did they deny any Jewish
connection to Jerusalem it's like you
hear the current Palestinian leader Abu
Mazin says the Jews are trying to
judeify Jerusalem
you know that's like saying the Chinese
are trying to signify Beijing or the
Russians a russifying mosque I mean it's
ridiculous but why do they do that
because the entire scaffolding of their
rejectionism collapses if we have a
legitimate claim to that territory they
don't have to deny their claim but they
can't make themselves take that one step
which is by far that would be a very
small step for a leader but a giant leap
towards peace the second they say that
we the Jews have a right to be in the
land of the Patriarchs the prophets and
the Kings then we're in a negotiation
then we have to work out a settlement
but they refuse to cross the Rubicon in
the aftermath of the abrahamic course
there's a couple of things we want to
get to which partly would be the pathway
forward for expanding the Abraham
Accords we don't want to forget about
that but we'll take a bit of a side
Venture into the Palestinian issue do
you see any reasonable pathway forward
word to movement towards peace on the
Palestinian side as a consequence or an
extension of what's being achieved with
the Abraham Accords
so yes I would say yes but my yes answer
is the right way to approach this is you
have in the Arab leaders particularly in
the Gulf the recognition as we discussed
that their interests mean in Alliance
with Israel what we should do is focus
on expanding that broadening it and
deepening it because you know we've had
peace with Egypt since 1979 Jordan with
1994 but it is a cold piece which is
certainly better than a hot War but you
didn't have any people to people or
business to business development they
could actually create the foundations
for something that would convince the
people in these societies that their
interests are served by having their
peace that peace the leaders get it but
the peoples don't yet there is Good Will
that's coming from the bottom in the
Emirates I think in Saudi Arabia in
Bahrain and other places in the region
but we should be trying to expand it now
what would happen if we expanded it if
we had not now six countries the the
Jordan in Egypt and the other four but
if we can get it to 10 12 what you'd be
left with is Iran you mentioned the Iraq
before Iran and its axis that is opposed
to Israel because you have this Shia
radical power in Iran it is a historical
aberration you know we talked about
anti-Semitism you know Jews have been
kicked around in so many different
societies we have a pretty good sense of
what a tolerant Society is so Western
democracies like the United States and
Canada are different in terms of history
in terms of acceptance and openness of
Jews and allowing them to become full
members of the society but if I have to
say like which ancient civilization
was relatively welcoming to the Jews
with all of its imperfections and
problems and programs occasionally and
things like that it's the Persian
Persian civilization Cyrus the Great
Persian king allowed the Jews to rebuild
the Temple uh in Jerusalem and
throughout history we had decent
relations and even when the Shah was
there before the Revolution in 1979
Israel had good relations with them and
also the United States did if this
regime in Iran would disappear tomorrow
and you would have a semblance of if you
don't want to call it a democracy but a
more open Society in Iran with some
representative government there you
would see good relations between Israel
and that country good relations between
Europe and that country I mean right now
Europe is doing appeasement anyway but
there would be no fire in them to have a
kind of global Revolution to export
their particular brand of Islam as as
Netanyahu said you know there's a fight
in Islam between the Sunni radicals and
the Shia radicals of who's going to be
the king of the militant Islamic Hill
but there's no place in their world for
Christians for Jews certainly not for
atheists for anybody who disagrees with
them
but if we're able to actually get to a
point where we've gotten the Israeli
Arab conflict as far as we can and all
we're left with is Iran and its proxies
I think then we're going to be left with
the Muslim Brotherhood and its effort to
push against it because that's another
force in the region that is against that
would be on the force of medievalism not
on the force of modernity then the hope
would be that there would be Palestinian
leaders
who would say guys you know the the Arab
armies and the Muslim armies are not
waiting us to to conquer Jerusalem
they're already on the other side
they're in an alliance with the Jews and
then hopefully there'd be courageous
leaders within that Society they could
emerge and at least start with something
called some sort of accommodation but I
really think people don't take ideology
seriously
and it's a it's a major flaw in
international diplomacy because we we I
mean you're the psychologist I don't
want to touch on your field but I think
people project
and if they
because they don't understand how
important their ideology which has
gotten wrapped up in a religious faith
that they have to sort of destroy the
Jews who are there if it were Christians
they would destroy that as well as well
the the radical Muslims they would try
to destroy like a crusader State they
would be there but the fact that its
Jews makes it worse because historically
the Jews were not seen as a powerful
actor when Muslims were defeated by
Christians okay they didn't like it but
they could understand it but for the
bully in the class who sees himself as
this war-like uh figure to be defeated
by the nerd in the class which is
supposed to be you know the George
Costanza of Seinfeld Fame you know the
George Costanza Jews they can't make
sense of it in fact the greatest scholar
of Islam
of the last century is is Bernard Lewis
and he said the birth of of European
style anti-Semitism in the Arab world
one of the factors that gave rise to it
was their defeat at the hands of Israel
in 1948 because they couldn't believe
that a Jewish Army could defeat them
there had to be other forces at work so
the traditional Protocols of the Elders
of Zion were Jews are manipulating all
these forces you don't really have
a history of that in the Muslim world
you had us having dimmy status like
Christians in the Muslim world but the
European style globalist Jew
anti-Semitism that actually came in the
way Lewis argues in the wake of Israel's
defeat of making sense
of why this happened
at the end of the day getting back to
the point if if we're able to finalize
as many peace agreements as we can with
the Arab world we will diminish those
forces on the medieval side their power
and then hopefully there would be forces
within Palestine Society I personally
believe many of them are in the business
sector
that would seek a long-term
accommodation because peace with Israel
would be great for the Palestinians
would be terrific for them but it
wouldn't be good for leaders it wouldn't
be good for their leaders because
they're more interested the Palestinian
leadership has been more interested in
the cause of the Palestinians and the
Palestinians themselves and the cause
would die when there's peace with Israel
but the Palestinian people would
actually their Futures would be improved
but they have to cross this Rubicon they
haven't crossed it yet one thing I can
tell you just to put a period on that
point
the only way it's going to happen is if
Israel stays extremely strong the
stronger we are a country militarily
economically technologically
diplomatically which is the abrahamic
gorgeous part of it the more there's a
sense within Palestinian Society the
time is not on their side that the train
is leaving or has left the station the
more likely you are to see people get on
board
okay so I want to turn to the issue of
Iraq at some point but I before that I
want to go back to the notion of
modernity versus medievalism and I want
to speak briefly on behalf of the
medievalists and I'm going to try to do
that from a Jewish perspective let's say
because one of the things that's very
interesting about the Jewish state is
that despite its status as a modern
democracy it's also unbelievably deeply
rooted in an ancient tradition and also
draws the ethical Wellspring of its
right to exist from that tradition and
so the Jews are wrestling in some real
sense with the problem of not precisely
medievalism versus modernity but
definitely tradition versus modernity
and I do have some sympathy for the more
fundamentalist end of the religious
Spectrum but let's say more specifically
the Islamic well and also the Jewish
Orthodox end of the spectrum and the
reason I say that is because
one of the problems with modernity is
that it's uh it's psychologic it it
frees you up technologically and it
produces uh a land of abundance in some
sense but the price that's paid is
ethical confusion and a kind of
corrosive and nihilistic cynicism that
emerges as a consequence of the
realization let's say that the world is
only objective in nature and that God is
dead and Western societies are paying a
very big price for this reflected for
example and places like South Korea and
Japan reflected not least in their
catastrophically low birth rates and
their dis what would you call their
their their their their lack of a belief
to that it's ethically appropriate to
move forward forthrightly into the
future and so you can imagine that on
the medievalist side and the Christian
fundamentalist side and the Jewish
Orthodox side there's this insistence
that goes something like look there's a
lot of things in these more traditional
views that have to be
um they're appropriate bulwarks against
the dissolute Tendencies of a
overweeningly intellectual modernism and
I do believe that's the case now I've
had some preliminary discussions with
people who are more on the
fundamentalist side of the Muslim
argument and they took me to task for a
variety of things and but did admit that
from their perspective even that there
is in some fundamental sense in the
ideal to be no compulsion in matters of
religious belief which is a doctrine
that has some origin in the in the Quran
itself now of course it's always subject
to interpretation but at least you can
make that case and so I would say do you
see a pathway you said that with regard
to the Palestinians that the proper
approach in some sense is to expand
Israel's
relationship with other Arab states
particularly on the Diplomatic and
economic fronts and that also opens up
the rest of the Arab world in some sense
to be the beneficiaries of the immense
Innovative capacity of the Israelis on
the technological and the governance
side what would you do to extend a hand
to the medievalists given that the Jews
are also rooted in an ancient tradition
and obviously value it immensely and
regard it as what the very ethical
Foundation of their claim to estate like
what's the pathway forward so one of the
things that really struck me after I had
this conversation uh with a more
traditional Muslim leader and I've
talked to lots of different Muslim
thinkers some of which are like Ayan
Hersey or quite profoundly anti-islam in
some real sense
the the what was very heartening to me
was that despite the rather fractious
nature of the conversation it was
watched by many millions of people it
got about two and a half million views
in the first two weeks it was posted and
most of them were Muslim and most of
them were traditionalist Muslims and all
of them said almost without exception
that they're absolutely thrilled that a
conversation like that could take place
uh where real issues were discussed
relatively peacefully but intensely and
that there was a sense that I got that
they were extremely pleased to be
regarded as valid participants at the
table of discussion so a lot a lot a lot
to unpack there I will say about the
Jews
first what's different is we're not a
missionizing a missionary faith
so they're you know for radical Islam
they have to spread their particular
brand of Islam all over the world that
is an article of faith that they have
certainly in all those regions that the
that Islam once held they have to go
back and sort of reconquer it and I
think if there is a radical Christian
group that would believe they have to
missionize to everybody around it would
also make it harder for them to develop
tolerance for those who disagree with
them but Jews are I think in a different
category because we've been you'd have
to go back to the Bible and how we
governed in the Bible and it certainly
wasn't Perfection there I mean I think
one of the one of the most remarkable
things about Jewish scripture is that
all the blemishes are put there for
everybody you know if you see the Jews
wandering through the desert you know
it's it's 40 years but the five stories
of them sinning or so whatever that
number is that all it's all there and
all the wards and everything and even
King David you know when he sins and the
prophet is telling telling him you know
you're the sinner that's the foundation
of the rule of law frankly and that and
that the Jewish leaders would put a king
being rebuked by anybody is I think
remarkable in itself so there was always
there was always there was always a
check on power but a people could argue
the jury is still out because you
haven't had sovereignty for 2 000 years
now you're working your way through the
modern world I think Israel is actually
an excellent example of reconciling
faith and freedom and I'm somebody who
was born and raised in the United States
which you may have mentioned at the top
and I always thought the greatness of
America one of the things is their
ability to reconcile faith and freedom
in a way that Europe didn't because it
sort of abandoned faith and in the
Middle East they couldn't accept freedom
and that America could do it and now a
lot of those things are breaking down in
the United States but let's take a step
back about five centuries and and here I
want to go back to something I read that
fascinated Me by Isaiah Berlin the Great
British philosopher he said that
sincerity is a complete completely
modern virtue it doesn't exist
before I think he said the 17th century
maybe the 16th century like this idea
that we have today that we accept other
people who disagree with us
fundamentally on theological matters
because we know that they are true to
their faith and they live by those
principles that did not exist before the
16th century so when Protestants were
killing Catholics and Catholics were you
know killing Protestants in Europe they
weren't saying you know about Thomas
More others well that guy really
believes what he believes and we have to
have appreciation for that no sincerity
is a completely you know modern virtue
virtue and I think is very interesting
James Q Wilson the great sociologist I
don't know if you had ever had a chance
to meet him but he wrote an essay I
think it was in City Journal about 20
years ago called the reform Islam needs
and in that essay he's explaining
how democracy Rose in the West
and it didn't rise because philosophers
got around a table and came up with
ideas he says it Rose because the of the
expedience of Kings because you had
these religious wars of fanaticism in
the 16th century and the Kings
understood that they're not going to
have young men to collect crops or to
gather taxes from if this continues for
more and more decades more and more
centuries so what you had was a freedom
of conscience that emerged then the
philosophers come and codified then you
expand the freedom a little bit and then
they codify of course it can be reversed
you can have a Nazi power that wants to
take you back all sorts of things can
happen like the way but what was
interesting to me
is he saying that Islam now and this is
right after 9 11. where you have the
Shia radicals and the Sunni radicals you
might be actually in that path where you
have these religious wars and in the
wake of these religious wars you have
the ability to have a space for Dissent
to have freedom of conscience and we
only see it in hindsight and it might
take many decades but frankly it took
hundreds of years
for these Democratic ideas to develop in
the west even the founders as you know
there was slavery in the United States
for a century you didn't have women that
had the right to vote for 150 years but
the ideas the ideas that they put in
place
in 1776 and later when they were
developing the Constitution those are
the ideas that still give the sense that
you can keep expanding it now could what
you see happening in the Middle East
with the forces of modernity facing the
forces of medievalism could out of this
tremendous violence and there's one
differences in a side between today and
the 16th century the ability of one
person or a small group of people to
kill many thousands tens of thousands
hundreds that's what's different
it could be that you're seeing the
Middle East in the 21st century is sort
of where Europe was in the mid 16th
century and you're moving hopefully to a
different future now we can speed that
up because of communications because of
ties between people so what may have
happened in 100
excuse me in 100 years can happen in 10
years but the real danger and this gets
to Iran
the real danger if you allow any of
these Fanatics to get their hands on
nuclear weapons because when you marry
militant Islam to nuclear weapons now
you're talking about danger to millions
or tens of millions of people so the
fires burnt themselves out in Europe in
the 16th century and you could kill a
lot of people
but this is a different order of
magnitude and I think that's why the
most important thing and this is our
view in Israel but it's not just of you
it's not just for Israel it's for all
our Arab neighbors it's also for Europe
it's also for the United States because
you know we're the little Satan as
Netanyahu says America is the great
Satan Europe gets aggravated maybe
they're a middle-sized Satan but their
designs are not just on Israel they're
on you to reverse history to upend the
whole order you know the Chinese are
trying to replace the United States
but here you have the militant Islam you
have a fanaticism that is trying to
upend the whole order and to think that
the traditional
rules of deterrence will work with a
nuclear-armed power whether it's a Sunni
or Shia power that's radical that is
armed with nuclear weapons to think that
the traditional cost benefits of
discerns and mutually assured
destruction will work you're gambling
with the future of the world now if
you're stuck in that situation because
you couldn't stop it well you're gonna
have to make the best of it but to allow
something like this to happen is
completely insane
and that's what's happening as we speak
where they're trying to negotiate a
nuclear deal with these ayatollahs in
Iran that are trying to export this
revolution around the world I mean it's
Insanity to do something like this and
this if this happens because you talked
about who are the forces of modernity
who are the forces of medievalism on
that medieval side the point the Shia
point is certainly wrong and all their
proxies to the region the Shia militias
in Iraq the the Shia Terror proxy in
Lebanon which is Hezbollah they're proxy
in Yemen which is the houthis they're
controlling through their proxies and
terrorism a huge swath of these
medievalists on the other side you have
as I said Al-Qaeda
and that was replaced really by ISIS but
Sunni fanaticism has not disappeared it
will reappear again and what you want to
do is move those forces of modernity and
here I would put those Gulf States not
because of their modern democracies
because they're trying to advance their
society so let's look at women's rights
in Saudi Arabia compared not to the
United States or to Canada or to Europe
but compared to women's rights in Saudi
Arabia 20 years ago look at what's
happening in sort of the opening of
these societies now if you think about
it in a 16th century context the
progress is remarkable yeah well that's
why I want to draw positive attention to
these developments because I think I
know psychologically
you know there's a there's a there's a
rule in terms of
establishing peace and prosperity and
the possibility of negotiation that
seems to work at every scale and so for
example in your marriage you might
criticize your wife if she does
something wrong and she might do the
same to you and there is some utility in
that but
BF Skinner who's a famous behaviorist he
could train animals to do virtually
anything and he said reward works a lot
better than threat and pain although you
can use threat and pain reward works
better but you have to pay a price for
it and so if Skinner was training a
route to climb a ladder and do little
dance on top of it and then climb down
the other side of the ladder I mean he
could train animals to do virtually
anything what he would do is he'd sit
and he'd watch the rat in the cage for a
very long time it was usually a hungry
route by the way and when the rat was
near the ladder he'd give it a food
pellet and then it would just hang
around near the ladder and then now and
then it would put its paw on the first
rung and he'd give it a food pellet and
then soon it was putting its paw on the
first rung a lot and then it would be
the second rung and by careful attention
and reward for due progress he could get
animals to do things as complex Skinner
taught pigeons to navigate guided
missiles by pecking on photographs in
reference to the landscape below
and so so the the and I know that's kind
of abstruse and it seems like a sideways
move but it's not because one of the
things that's very much worth doing and
I think you captured that very well in
the last thing that you said in in one
of my books I have an adage which is
compare yourself to who you were
yesterday and not to who someone else is
today and the idea is your best
measure is your previous self and you
should try for incremental Improvement
at the rate you can manage and you
should recognize that incremental
Improvement in yourself and you should
reward it and you shouldn't denigrate it
because it isn't a Leap Forward that's
too big for you to manage and it's not
getting you to wear someone else who is
hypothetically better off than you might
be because all of that's
counterproductive and when I see these
things happening in the Middle East
let's say on the Saudi front as you just
pointed out from a western perspective
we might say well you know you're a
little hard on your women uh and we also
know that rights granted to women are a
very good predictor of economic progress
as it turns out and also of educational
status among children and so there are
both ethical and Technical reasons why
that might be a bad idea and we can
shake our fingers at you because you're
not doing that and to some degree
perhaps that's appropriate but more
importantly if we do see something like
incremental progress in that direction
and we want to facilitate it we should
be saying hey look man and this is
what's happening on the Abraham Accord
side is for all of your faults and ours
let's point out this looks like a nice
move forward and it really is
unfortunate as far as I'm concerned that
more positive light hasn't been shed on
the Abraham Accords themselves and on
the contributions of the people who made
them possible and I would say that's
particularly although you not uniquely
true of the Saudis
and and it's it's very heartening to me
given the complexities of the last 30
years in 9 11 and the wahhabis and all
of that
that the Saudis were behind this and
that they are willing to they appear
willing to move forward I I I agree with
you said it I want to
I want to explain why why I think it is
because I think it also explains the
event that surfaced the Abraham Accords
as well you know when I gave an exit
interview when I was finishing my time
as Ambassador and they said who's next
you know who's next you've done four in
the last six months who's next and I
said nobody but I want to explain why I
said nobody and unfortunately I wanted
to continue I believe actually the
current U.S Administration could
continue it they just have to completely
change their policies and I'll explain
why
and this gets also to Saudi Arabia and
the whole view of Saudi Arabia vis-a-vis
Iran in terms of who is your partner uh
in the region
what I said to you before about the
failure at the beginning to get the
Trump Administration to sort of see it I
said also they didn't waste time because
they shifted U.S policy and this shift
was critical to help surface the Abraham
Accords again I want to draw the
distinction between the surfacing of the
relations between Israel and Arab States
versus what happens underneath the
surface because underneath the surface
since that change in 2012 11 10 that was
all moving forward underneath the
surface in various different degrees and
speeds but it was moving underneath the
surface the Abram Accords in 2020 was
the surfacing event now what contributed
what facilitated surfacing it the most
important policy was the U.S
confrontational posture Visa V Iran and
I'll explain it when the U.S is
confronting Iran as a policy they're
confronting the saudi's worst enemy and
the people in Saudi Arabia get that
because they're firing Rockets into
their airports they're the ones
attacking their oil facilities the same
thing in the Emirates who's attacking
their ships who's firing drones who's a
threat to them when the U.S is
confronting their worst enemy you open
up the political space for these Arab
leaders to come into an open alliance
with Israel okay that was critical and
Trump changed from appeasing Iran to
confronting Iran now all of a sudden an
MBS who doesn't say didn't say it
publicly but behind the scenes an mbz
and others can look at their people and
say guys
you know you see on September 15 2020
you see you got uh Trump and you've got
Netanyahu standing there yeah we know
we've said all these things about the
Israelis for many many decades but guess
what that Trump guy he just took out
qasim suleimani January 2nd 2020. he's
confronting Iran he's starving them of
the cash that they're using to fuel
their War Machine in the region we need
to stand with him and that Netanyahu is
leading you know is authorizing all of
these operations for Israel to attack
Iranian positions in Syria and do all
sorts of things in the region against
Iran so you've now opened the political
space for these leaders to move into a
public alliance with the United States
now once the U.S shifts its policy
towards appeasement why in the world are
the leaders in the region why are they
going to stand with the president who is
actually undermining their own interests
in endangering their peoples you've
actually shrunk all the political space
so the first important policy is you
need to confront Iran an Administration
that confronts Iran will move us closer
to expanding the Abraham supports and
deepening them the second thing that
they did is they embraced Israel the
Trump Administration Jerusalem the Golan
Heights all these issues that were made
where many people said it was going to
prevent peace from happening it will be
a big blow to peace well it didn't
create peace between Israelis and
Palestinians but that wasn't happening
anyway for a century for the reasons we
discussed but what message did it send
to the Arabs in the region in the Gulf
it said that if they want to get closer
to Washington they should move closer to
Jerusalem so you actually made them
understand the importance of having a
solid relationship with Jerusalem and
here you have to say that Trump by not
abandoning MBS after the khashoggi
incident which we can talk about by not
abandoning him he showed that he was
actually a reliable friend usually the
way the Arabs in the region see is if
Israel if the United States is is in
friction with Israel which was the case
for most of the Obama Administration on
settlements on this and that that's a
sign to them that the US is not a
reliable Ally because they know the
Israel U.S relationship is fundamentally
different because we share interests we
share values it's very very deep they
get it so if the U.S is now con is
bothering Israel and turning the
building of Jewish apartments in
Jerusalem into a world crisis these are
not going to be reliable people and they
get it if they confront Iran and they
Embrace Israel they move actually the
Arabs closer and the third factor which
was critical
take the veto away from the Palestinians
stop chasing down that rabbit hole so
the Trump Administration ultimately it
stopped chasing them because he made the
decision on Jerusalem and the
Palestinians effectively after that
decision cut off ties with Trump and
guess what Jared Kushner and Trump's
team they didn't rush after them they
said guys we're here you know our number
in the meantime they put forward a plan
eventually that said if you want to go
through the door for a realistic
solution to this conflict where both
sides will get something and both sides
will compromise we're there to support
you if not we're moving ahead so the
three legs of this stove in terms of U.S
foreign policy are confront Iran Embrace
Israel and take away the veto from the
Palestinians now look at the Biden
Administration they're appeasing Iran
which is the worst thing they can do I
can't they're not embracing Israel to
the extent the Trump Administration has
but they haven't fully reversed it and
on the issue of the veto for the
Palestinians they're slowly but surely
trying to move the Palestinian issue
back into the center in the name of
helping the Palestinians it actually
just hurts them because if we would
actually move ahead with the Abram
Accords then we could get those forces
within Palestinian Society who wanted to
accommodate us now a few weeks ago on my
podcast diplomatically incorrect before
Biden made a visit to Israel
I said what Biden can do to win the
Nobel Prize because look Biden they'll
give the Nobel Prize to they'll never
give the Nobel Prize to Trump no matter
what he does they'll never give it to
Netanyahu no matter what he does but
they gave it to Obama before he did
anything they will certainly give it to
Biden for actually doing something I
said here's how you win the Nobel Prize
you go to Saudi Arabia
and you tell the Saudis here's how we're
going to deal with a khashoggi incident
it was a horrible incident we're putting
it behind us a b c and d okay here's how
we're going to deal with the problem of
Yemen because the Saudis having Yemen
what Israel has in Lebanon they've got a
terror organization these houthis that
are are establishing essentially a
beachhead for Iran to attack them from
the south like the Iranians have a beach
head against Israel from the north with
Hezbollah to attack us from the north
one of the first acts the Obama the
Biden Administration did was to remove
sanctions on the houthis for no reason
imagine the message that sent to Saudi
Arabia so you have to tell the Saudis
here's how we're going to solve
khashoggi here's how we're going to deal
with the issue of Yemen
now I'm going to change my policy and
this is what Biden needs to win the
Nobel Prize I'm going to change my
policy 180 degrees on Iran I'm going to
confront the Iranian regime with all
elements of American power and if there
was a credible military threat Iran's
nuclear facilities they would not break
out to the bomb we would put crippling
sanctions on them we'll reach out to the
dissidents in Iran who hate this regime
as well meaning you have a clear
strategy to confront Iran and he tells
MBS he says I don't want to go back to
the American people and tell them I
started a new war in the Middle East for
you I need one thing I need to go back
to the American people and say I brought
peace in the Middle East between
Israelis and Saudis and that's really
the big prize now if I'm MBS and I want
this relationship with Israel I want it
for my security and economic interest
that's my opportunity to look at my own
people and say America has shifted we
have now a bipartisan policy confronting
Iran I'm standing with a president who's
confronting our worst enemies that will
give him the political space to make a
piece and I think that by the way that
what I just told you right now could be
done in six months it doesn't require
rocket science it's a it I I think the
chances of it happening approach zero I
want to be optimistic so I'll give it
point one percent because they are
wedded divided Administration to a
policy of appeasing this regime in
Tehran and that begins and ends their
whole
problem with the Abraham Accords it's
not that they don't support it it's that
the policies that they've put in place
are not facilitating it are actually
undermining it now the good news is the
fundamentals that I spoke about of
the rise of Iran the rise of Sunni
radicalism America is not in the region
what happened with the Arab Spring those
fundamentals still exist
and so therefore the potential for the
Diplomatic breakthrough will survive
this Administration the one thing that
would undermine it if an American
Administration decided to send 500 000
troops to the Middle East and establish
military bases however they the the
bloom would be off the Israeli roads
okay or if Israel lost its technological
Edge and all of a sudden we had a brain
drain because our government decided to
hike up taxes and not let people afford
apartments in Israel and they all left
and went to Silicon Valley or someone
else and you wouldn't have an innovation
engine as long as we have an innovation
engine a powerful military and Intel and
weapons making capability and the U.S is
not there
Israel is the best show in town for them
and they understand that and I think
what we need to do is work as fast as we
can with them to build the bridges the
ones I'll tell you what will happen if
if this deal is done and by the time the
podcast airs the deal could be done or
could be done 10 days later two weeks
later
you're going to see two things happen
simultaneously that are going to be a
little bit confusing for people
underneath the surface the Arabs will
move closer to Israel out of fear of the
rise of Iran because the nuclear deal
gives Iran a Glide path to a nuclear
Arsenal that is paved with gold
so they're going to be frightened to
death of Iran and its Rising power and
they're going to move underneath the
table to Israel but they will move above
the table towards Iran because power in
the region will shift in that uh way and
you're already seeing signs of it
where the Emirates who didn't have an
ambassador for many years in Iran are
now sending somebody back there's open
meetings the reason all of this stuff is
happening is not that they change the
view they know exactly what this regime
in Tehran is they just know that in
Washington the policy is a capital A
appeasement and it's not changing and
you can shift the whole region fairly
quickly so I would hope the bid
Administration that has over two years
in its term will do it if not a new
Administration that comes in will be
able to pick up these Peace Accords much
faster than you think with a shift in
policy much faster than people think
because the Strategic moment is there
and I think it's going to be there
probably for 20 years or 30 years now if
Iran I say one thing if Iran goes down
if that regime goes down and you have a
different relationship
it'll actually make making peace with
our Sunni Arab states harder but I'll
take that as a problem let me let's work
on figuring out how to solve that
problem if that regime in Tehran that
openly calls and actively Works to
destroy Israel
um let's let's deal with the problem of
them going down and having the Iranian
people actually govern themselves and
have a a responsible government there
that won't be hell-bent on Conquering
the Middle East and half the world
that's a very good place to end I think
unless you have anything else
specifically wanted to say yes I want to
say for the record because you what you
said is you said if sometimes you
criticize your wife and she criticizes
you I never criticize my wife for the
record
yeah well you're probably a wiser man
than me then so I appreciate you walking
through that all for me and for all my
Watchers and listeners and uh I found it
extremely
um almost unbearably educational in some
sense because it's an awful lot of well
it's an awful lot of information to try
to digest in the 90-minute period it's
right there you just have to put that
little crumb on the top where the Paul
can reach we're we're very close right
it's so heartening you know to see that
this pathway forward beckons and it's so
useful I'm so happy that I can play a
small role in shedding some light on it
because it seems to me so significant
and important and so much worthy of
reward and so I'll probably ask my
people who've been in contact with you
to recommend other people maybe closer
to the Arab world itself that I could
talk to if they would like to about the
Abraham Accords maybe someone I suppose
what would be optimal would be someone
on the Saudi side in some real sense and
so we didn't get a chance to talk about
Iraq I can I think we'll leave that
because it's another rabbit hole and it
would take a long time to go down but
well it's somebody it it's it's whether
Iran is effectively in control of Iraq
through the Shia militias that it has
there I I will tell you one thing that I
would like to say in this battle between
medievalism and modernity is not a
battle of tradition versus modernity I
actually believe that that part of the
world will remain traditional for a very
long time and not only do I have no
problem with it I actually think the
path to peace will go with the
traditional forces not the fnatic forces
the traditional forces in this Society
it is it is interesting
um that many of the people involved
in the Abraham Accords were traditional
Jews
uh or traditional on the Arab side or
people on the Israeli side which was
actually there were only about three
people in Israel who knew that the
Abraham Accords was about to happen but
I don't necessarily think that it's a
coincidence meaning the ability to deal
with traditional people on the other
side and not working on the assumption
that the path to peace is really about
these people abandoning their traditions
and their ideals you know I always
thought that was a mistake when it comes
to promoting democracy if you tell
people choose between a democracy and
your tradition they'll choose tradition
but there's no reason why they have to
choose and I think America for a good
part of its history was a perfect
example of that which it was a very
vibrant democracy and an extremely
traditional Society measured by Church
attendance and all these different
metrics that they have so I don't see
any inherent
um uh disconnect between those two
things and I actually think the
legitimate forces in these societies are
are the traditional forces we mentioned
Saudi Arabia like to me you want to know
a sign
of how close we are to a steric
breakthrough is when the head of the
Muslim world league I can't remember his
name off the top of my life in Saudi
Arabia
he visited Auschwitz as an act of
solidarity now without MBS support that
does not happen and he also gave they
ensured that he would be given the
sermon
in the mosque in the in the important
mosque in Saudi Arabia before Biden's
visit this same ship now it's clear that
MBs is trying to move his country into
the 21st century it's clear it's clear
that the situation with khashoggi was
abhorrent and it's clear that you have
to have some show that this is that is
unacceptable but to throw out as I said
at the time in real time by the way and
because Netanyahu didn't throw them
under the bus and Trump didn't throw
them under the bus that also helped I
said in real time a few days after the
incident khashoggi thing is terrible uh
but don't throw out the prince with the
bathwater that would be a huge mistake
don't throw out a prince that is
confronting the islamists in his country
changing this whole Wabi fanaticism that
is spreading around the world and it's
trying to propel his country forward
decades if not centuries now if you're
1550 it's very hard to go to 2020 in one
day I mean if he could move to the 19th
century and anymore more open society
that would be a great gift to the region
and hopefully the region will all have
free societies around us but that can
take some time in the meantime
these forces in this region they're on
our side they are confronting these
medievalists the ones who want to take
us back and so therefore they're the
ones that should be supported and it
just so happens that this completely
overlaps with the Abraham Accord so the
important thing for me is for people to
recognize what changed in the region
what enabled the potential breakthrough
so that policy makers will continue it
it wasn't luck one of the reasons why
they want to avoid it is probably
because of the politics regarding Trump
because it happened on his watch the
politics regarding you know Netanyahu it
wasn't the players that the Nobel Prize
committee wanted to be involved in it
but guess what Trump was the one that
recognized Jerusalem Trump was the one
that withdrew from the Iran deal Trump
was the one that took out suleimani
right and Netanyahu did all the things
that he did these were the leaders who
actually enabled us to have this
breakthrough and one last thing about
Iran and Saudi Arabia you had Salman
rushti and I'm not I can't say that I
read his books but growing up I always
saw him as like a great liberal
intellectual who wanted to live in a
free society and he always stood behind
that so now you have this man
who's who was stabbed multiple times
and the outcry for what happened with
rushti is nothing compared to what
happened with khashoggi
and that has everything to do with
politics meaning Iran is trying to order
hits
on Americans
on the former National Security adviser
John Bolton on a female democracy
activist that they tried to send
somebody to killer one thing after
another on U.S soil no response virtual
silence against the regime that is
glorifying this when khashoggi happened
how did the Saudi regime respond they
were embarrassed okay so people will say
well he ordered it so they said okay
these people were responsible but nobody
in the Saudi regime was saying this was
a good thing they said this was a
terrible thing and the prince wasn't
involved so people will believe what
they want to believe but they said this
is bad the sense of Shame
was tremendous that this was a a
terrible and they understood that you
can't just do this openly in the modern
world I'm not saying that if it would
have happened that they would have
expressed regrets but because of what
happened
they had a tremendous sense of Shame and
uh and and issued they issued statements
condemning it one after the other look
at the how the Iranians are dealing with
rushdeep
you don't have any condemnation of this
guy who killed rashti they glorify they
think this is a good thing
and I think that tells you the
difference of this regime one regime was
embarrassed about it and wants to move
ahead and one regime was glorifying it
and wants to take us all back and that's
a real big difference in the region and
I think if we focus our efforts on
expanding the peace which implicit in is
this confrontation of Iran we can
actually receive pretty good outcomes
much faster than people think not
perfect but pretty good outcomes and I
think that the Middle East deserves it
Israel does the Arabs do and ultimately
the Palestinians do because if we're
able to do that then I think the chances
of having those accommodation as forces
emerge are going to be much higher well
that's as optimistic uh ending as we
might hope for from such a deep dive
into such a complex topic and it really
is heartening to hear it and that
there's a pathway forward of that sort
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com